foreign
through the next 20 minutes with no more
gay [__] I got you we'll probably be the
least gay show this month I got you fam
let me take let me show you about
something I saw on day wave and I had to
bring it to the main show as soon as I
saw it okay what is going on here so you
know we've played Darman videos before
yes on the show and and we've talked
about on the show how there's like
clones of dark man like the grift works
right if the grift works there's a bunch
of people that have AV Equipment or they
rent it from and then they make these
videos and look honestly it works like
this video has 310 000 views uh six to
four six thousand likes so they're
making money now
I want you to read the title of the
video and then we're going to play the
video can you please read the title of
the video out loud for me please
um hot mom takes autistic son's dick pic
you won't believe it okay
all right you ready I've been dying to
share this is all right I don't believe
it but let's go right hold on this is
how the videos are now for those who
don't know Darman look up Darman he's a
guy that has these fake like after
school specials and a lot of people have
been
copying him ready to see how this starts
this is the autistic age you're about to
see coming up on tomorrow's teachings
what is happening I can't I know
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay look I I can't wait to show you
this verse oh my God so
so you can do pretty much whatever you
want on YouTube as long as the guys if
you're being you're being helpful that's
what I think is happening yes
I
almost want to get into this business
yeah to see what we could get away with
oh hi John how may I help you
Frozen is that you wait can I ask can I
already point something out
who greets somebody you already know or
have familiarity with like that that's
her landlord by the way just so you know
but okay but if I don't know if my
landlord knocked on my door
I wouldn't go oh hello John how may I
help you
I would go oh John what's going on man
how you doing
uh it's so I love people that just read
write these terrible chat GPT quality
scripts and just hello John how may I
help you he's not calling you you're not
at a call center
art of mine in the chat says I need to
see him being wheeled in it again oh you
will trust me
please come in I'll make you a cup of
tea I don't have time for that I'm only
here for the please it's already made
and I have access let the balding
Armenian man in your house sure what it
won't take much of your time what that's
good okay to stand just for a bit then
you won't regret it it's much specialty
it gets please trust me on this one what
is going on you'll see it'll make sense
oh boy
so
how's work Megan cut the crap
you know why I'm here I do
oh yes you do and it's not for this
horrible tea
it tastes like you just put it in a
microwave filled with bacon look
I don't have the money right now I'm in
a bit of a dilemma you always say that I
swear just give me just give me a week
or two rent was due on the first and now
it's the 13th I don't like chasing you
down for the money you owe me I'm sorry
just
just please no
look I don't understand why you can't
pay your rent on time I see you buy
designer clothes and going out on
expensive trips all the time we're gonna
keep that take
how did you know that we follow each
other on Instagram
oh I'm going to have to evict you from
this property I've already given you too
many chances
what if
I could show you a good time what is
happening you forget Megan I'm gay
wow this has all the [__] it says it
says everything it says every Twist and
Turn also I like the fact that she's
just like
first of all the name's Megan she's
obviously this fat Mexican Filipino
actually and it's like she's not
attractive at all like these are the
most unattractive people I've ever seen
in a video those are people who need
something for their IMDb I love this
what it's time for you to pack your
things and get at it please there must
be something you could do for me
wouldn't it be hang on wouldn't it be
there must be something I can do for you
yes but we just keep one take care sorry
it's time for you to
who is that I have a pet seal
oh do you not
oh well that's why you can't pay your
rent because you're feeding a pet seal
Jack
yes
what is he doing why is he doing that
oh he's [__]
give me one so keep in mind the city's
autistic wait to this wild twist oh well
I already saw the uh I already saw the
[__] uh what's it called what the the
beginning part oh no no no no no that's
nothing you haven't seen why how he
became autistic
yeah there's a house he came yep
oh
okay first of all we just so why is he
like simple Jack oh my God
what happened to him
last month I was here he was wait
he was fine
he became a severely autistic so at 20
years old he became autistic oh wait to
see how normal say hi Jack
[Music]
this is the best where did you find this
Frozen sent it to me Jesus
what happened Jack didn't have his seat
yes this is a troll please let God let
the [__] kid in the wheelchair be
the one who wrote all of this just wait
you'll see just wait I became
Jack didn't have his seat belt on
a car cut me off and I swerved off the
road and hit a tree you know how
traumatic a brain injury can make you
autistic wait so was the tree made of
vaccines I don't understand
it was one of those Pfizer Oaks that
they hit it was at the moderna Forest
Jack was sitting in the middle
the faces he's making I love I would be
like oh okay so he's not autistic he's
[__] so you Nick Hogan to this kid
yeah yeah okay
straight on his head Tomatoes potato
potato
that's very good very good very good
sorry to hear that
I'm glad he survived well
I mean you're probably also it was only
a month ago he'd still be in the
hospital getting his brain examined yeah
I wish you would have and also like yeah
if you're this profoundly [__]
nobody's glad you survived I know
everyone says it but they don't everyone
says it out loud because it's the thing
to say but you know there's another
there's another there's another twist
well I already I already know where this
is going what do you think it's no I
wanna I wanna see if you can guess I
didn't guess it what do you think it's
going the gay guy is the one that wants
to see the kid's dick nope I thought
that too he's not oh that's not it
there's two possibilities all right
the mom is gonna steal the phone to take
a picture of the [__] kid stick to
frame him you'll have no idea oh that's
actually good that's good I like that
or the [__] kid is not [__] and
this is all just an act
virgie's close
all the trips and expenses are for my
boy I just wanted to have a have a good
remaining life and I can only so you
went on all these trips and did all this
stuff in a month yes in one month if you
are so weak for my job because
this guy is the best this guy's living
it up the only one here to take it and I
like that the guys the kids playing this
up like like like you'd only see in like
a 90s or early 2000s comedy like yeah
that's [__] over the top [__] guy
it's like a [__] you know what it's
like you would make fun of a [__] in
school like dude
I won't charge you any rent for the next
year you're a terrible landlord and a
very bad businessman it'll be on me
okay well that's not anything at all I'm
here for you too
this is so oh ready for Twist number one
there's like three twists here's twist
number one is this the Kaiser Jose well
this is one of them
thank God I put you in acting classes
mom I can't keep doing this Virgie with
a point on the board okay wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute keep doing this
yeah oh no yeah you'll find out that
this has been a long con
the whole conversation they had
suggested that he just found out about
all of us yeah yeah but but he's been
but he's been using them with other
people pretending to be [__] which
is different landlords every month yes
no but not really but other stuff you'll
see I can't keep doing watch this that
that five foot one Filipino slapped that
six foot three jock that part is
actually believable yeah
you say any any about this I'll put you
in the ice box for a full week what does
that mean do you understand
yes Mom all right how much longer do I
have to keep acting like this forever
you understand
acting like this is super beneficial to
me okay super
super beneficial it's a very natural
dialogue it's it's disrespectful towards
Kids that actually have autism I don't
care
I just got out of a Year's worth of rent
it's not bad I make fun of I would
pretend to be a [__] guy for one day
to just pretend
you have to keep you wait your life
you'll never learn
dad said I don't care what Dad said
that sounds like it was written by David
Lynch after a traumatic head injury dad
is dead nothing has said matters anymore
you listen to me
sure
dad
two points on the board for Virgie she's
getting uh
that's the dad spoilers by the way
hanging out with Steve C before he died
oh
[Music]
rip Steve C
stop whining I didn't say anything he
was literally sitting there I need to
think you're actually autistic I just
missed Dad it's hard without him it's
just
it just sucks not knowing where he went
I feel like he's still out there
somewhere he's gone forever he's never
coming back no get your crap kill them
together we have a meeting with a mayor
wait what with all my hair outstanding
man with a mayor yeah also they set up a
lot of meetings with different mayors
why do you have a meeting
okay how about this let's play a
guessing game why do you think they have
a meeting with the mayor
this one's really hard because you like
you have to base your guess off of what
they think exactly
that's why this is a tough one
with the mayor
a few hours later
we appreciate that Mr Mayor please call
me Mike now okay Mike mayor we're gonna
send you one hundred thousand dollars
wait what they're gonna send him one of
the mayor is sending them a hundred
thousand dollars of what town
probably Berkeley somewhere in
California yeah
it's a hundred thousand it just is a
hundred thousand but you got to cut his
dick off oh see I made it made sense I
just made it
oh
okay there's twenty thousand dollars I
would have made it twenty and said it's
a grant to cut your kid's dick off
that's getting paid for some of the
medical bills
goodness Mike are they oh
would be a record of the accident also
also what's the disembodied voices the
mayor Mr House
amazing your story has more oh a new
Contender has entered I need you to get
me the Platinum chip okay this all
well okay but he's on voice like that's
his girlfriend no it's supposed to be a
zoom meeting oh
that's just supposed to be his
girlfriend what's wrong with you
just walked in the house yeah because
that's his girlfriend well she's not in
on it I mean no she's not why I mean why
wouldn't you just let her in on it
oh my God I think Jack is having a panic
attack we have to go now Jack why do you
sound like that wait what was that so
two things are two things are going on
with her voice you ready one she's four
and two she's deaf
my guess she also kind of looks Armenian
so she might be related to that other
dude we have a few more questions for
Chuck
what are you doing here last night Chuck
asked me to come over
Marley Matlin baby foreign Mari Matlin
oh you thought this video was done with
the twist you'll have no [__] clue I
found the best videos
gorgeous that's even better
it's even better you can talk to other
[__] model you could get her like
discount of course yeah yeah her [__]
self-esteem is real low
what's wrong with him can't you tell he
is autistic now with you he's autistic
now
[Music]
oh salmonella
salmonella
this can't be I was literally talking to
him last night last night okay I can't
wait to see what is going on
there is so much going on
best video on the internet well thanks
thank you we have few
more to get done a few more calls Maybe
how could she read his lips when he's
just saying duh
she starts blowing him I also notice
they got the cheap prop wheel triggers
missing one of the arms
it's pretty jeez
[Music]
it's best for you to live now before he
gets hurt even more what I'm not going
anywhere oh you guys forgot that there's
still a dick pic coming wow I need to be
with him yeah I did actually I totally
forgot about yeah you got oh somebody
forgot about the dick pics
like this
just please let me stay over for today
and I'll leave for good
ah fine
by getting some food get some raw
chicken
what what not chicken you heard me
do you want him to get better or not not
really he's hilarious he got it from
salmonella so you're gonna fight fire
with fire yeah okay hold on hold on Get
Ready Get Ready Get Ready room Focus
you say a word to her that you're faking
this
I will send this to your friends and
they will know how small it is how do
you know how big your son's dick is
first of all first of all man
that would be the worst way to Blackmail
me because I wouldn't care I would think
that I would go I've never thought to do
that I I would send a dick pic to all my
friends it'd be hilarious [__]
hilarious women don't understand how
horrible guys are to each other yeah it
wouldn't bother me at all you send the
picture be like you have any gum in my
pants is your dick out
oh no oh
don't know how small your dick is hey
guys my dick small
anyway
what's up that's Mercy's that's Mercy's
Tinder bio it says realistic
expectations
eating we're all checking on Bartlett
what the hell all right that's gross I
can't even look at that actually eat it
obviously
where'd the Bone Go
I was about to say that was like a
wingette
well
I'm Jack nap time
[__] he needs it for his little
autistic brain
he's a little autistic what is it are
they smaller that's the name of
radiohead's new album
and he's not autistic he's obviously
profoundly [__] meant it mentally
what do you think autistic people are
predators
oh
here to help just let me know
she's pretty right so you take her out
she's dressed up the nines and then you
introduce her you're like hi this is
this is my girlfriend you feel bad man
oh no hi Jane ma'am are your wisdom
teeth trying to escape
[Music]
hi Chuck Mr Football goes this is a
masterpiece
I love you
yeah
Simple Jack
dramatic music we have SIMPLE Jack
now wait till you see how it turns
around because there's the last two
minutes are amazing because it shows you
what made her change her mind
oh no is there gonna be a ghost dream
secret she's having a Disney Dream
sequence she's having right now
who had zombies on the board none of you
[__] none of you [__] said zombie on
the board nobody had that can I can I
give you guys some advice and I'm not
telling you how to do your jobs I'm
trying to make anybody's worst day ever
at their job but I mean I feel like
I've watched some shows right where
they're really stretching out like no
story and I feel like you have your show
today yeah you have the opposite problem
where I feel like you could have just so
many 10 episodes here a couple Seasons
releases
way to deactivate is with raw chicken
oh God we're we're out of raw chicken oh
no
[Music]
that's a zombie just walked right in
no Mom don't let him eat me
there's no blood because they attacked
the Airbnb couch dirty oh my God good
catch
99 can I say 99 grad night you're not
old enough to have been to Disney grad
night in 1999.
no no no no I thought I lost you what
I'm so sorry
for everything I realized that I could
lose you at 80. that's it that's all she
still murdered his hot father don't
forget that so you're a complete
psychopath who needs to be in prison
but you had one dream about zombies and
now you're a good person they're cool
now
[Music]
is the door the hot deaf Armenian girl
coming back I wish
I love you too
listen You'll never have to act autistic
again okay well except when the landlord
comes by right I've told Virgie that too
you might have to fix the sink yeah I'll
start being a good mom oh good you're
gonna start now he's like 25. murdered
your husband yeah and he looks like he
plays college basketball so I don't know
how yeah seriously
oh
here we go another wrap up hey guys we
hope you enjoyed that video and the
important lesson
if someone has a disability that makes
them no different from the restaurant of
course we're all the same and we should
all treat each other the same this guy
rules brilliantly done this is has to be
a troll the stuff that he just the stuff
that that had like three or four four
terms of service violations that would
have got us popped on you of course but
the reason he did and I'm not shooting
on him because this is smart the reason
he got away with all that [__] stuff
was because he framed it into you can't
you're not supposed it's like it's like
the Trevor morbid you can't say I want
to kill the president United States it's
like that as long as you frame it that
way you're fine uh that is really
[__] this guy rules uh sorry I was
busy texting my girlfriend Nancy from
stranger thing it's getting kind of
serious you're not really dating her all
right I have to follow this thing now
yeah it's called tomorrow
that's [__] great and I'm gonna tell
you something uh I've skimmed through
I've skimmed through their their videos
and just the titles alone like when you
look at some just the titles alone like
it's gonna pop you I want to show you
one uh
uh let's see here white Teacher Calls
black kid the n-word
uh evil nanny drowns little kid in pool
Tudor falls in love with student
Karen mom shoots daughter's boyfriend
boyfriend Jesus Karen hunts down
Mexicans
this is wife cheats on husband white cop
frames innocent black guys this guy's
brilliant uh maid sleeps with fat gamer
you won't believe it
so this guy's great